it has been revealed that relating to
this leak of documents classified
documents that has been revealed that it
is the source of the leak was a 21 year
old member of the Massachusetts Air
National Guard by the name of Jack
teczera a 21 year old member of the
Massachusetts Air National Guard who is
the source of the the leak of what can
only be described as a trove of
classified
documents uh and the more we find out
about this leak the more extraordinary
it becomes President Biden as you can
see there is about to address the Irish
Parliament he appeared to suggest
earlier in Dublin that the U.S
government was close to identifying the
leaker well they have now done that I
think we can have a very quick word
before President Biden speaks with U.S
correspondent James Matthews James they
appear to have got their man
indeed no official confirmation from the
FBI but their manhun has been ongoing
Mark and as you say he the the name
identified by our colleagues at NBC here
in the states is Jack takes here a 21
year old
who is a national Guardsman he works for
the intelligence wing of the
Massachusetts Air National Guard and it
raises all sorts of questions
particularly
why did he have access to the kind of
information that we have seen leaked
information about the battlefield in
Ukraine about foreign governments
interfering in elections he had left all
sorts of clues of course this
information had been leaked over many
months he used a name or G in this
particular chat room where the
information was produced so there was a
digital identity the FBI investigators
they knew the name
the corner of the internet that he
occupied and the new Associates in that
chat room